good morning Hank it's Friday and I'm
still locked in the little room but I'm
not actually locked in it anymore
because I turned in my draft at one
o'clock in the morning last night and
I'm free ish today maybe some of you
have gone through this feeling when you
finish something really big and you turn
it in and then you have no idea what to
do with yourself right away you feel
like you've been hit on the head with a
plank and just sort of go ah
that's that's basically where I'm at
today anyway a lot of you had questions
about writing and you left him in the
comments and I thought today I was going
to do some questions so let's get right
to it question I really want to write
but I'm afraid that I suck how can I get
over this fear that I suck I'm going to
tell you something that's going to run
contrary to what you normally think as
nerdfighters as nerdfighters you want to
decrease worldsuck
but what I'm going to tell you today is
that you should dare to suck let me let
you in on a little secret when you are
learning to write you are going to suck
you were going to suck a lot you're just
gonna keep sucking for a while and
you're gonna feel like you're sucking
and actually that's a sign that you're
completely on the right path because
when you are learning things do you suck
at them imagine you went down the street
you bought a violin you wouldn't just
bring it home and automatically say to
all your friends hey I bought a violin
you want to hear me play no you would go
and you would practice for like eight to
10 years and then you'll be like hey I'm
playing at Carnegie Hall look at me go
you have to suck first there are some
things that you really aren't supposed
to suck at like for example I really
suck it crossing the street at
roundabouts in England
[Music]
I mean if you suck at that that can have
serious consequences writing there are
no real serious consequences to sucking
you know you don't have to be afraid
that the first thing you turn out is
going to be a huge masterpiece or it's
going to be that big novel of makes a
billion zillion dollars don't worry
about that don't worry that it's not
good nobody that's the great thing about
writing and not publishing right away so
you can write tons of stuff that sucks
just precisely why when people write to
me when you're you know 16 and 17 and 18
and you say you know I've written a book
I read stories all the time I want to
publish them how can I do that I say no
don't do it don't stop because you
haven't sucked enough yet and you maybe
think you know I really do I really
really do suck no I think you're under
estimating how much I suck Maureen but
I'm not you haven't sucked long and hard
enough and I did I just actually say
that gas main stocking is not just a
part of the learning process it's part
of the professional process as well
first drafts like the one I turned in at
one o'clock this morning basically
exists to sock wrong they're the first
pass so they're my first attempt of the
story and they're going to get changed
and ripped apart I mean lots of writers
I know we sit and we laugh about the
incredible sock titude of our first
drafts but you have to go there and you
have to try stuff out and you have to
suck at it sometimes I hear this phrase
writing is rewriting well it's a hundred
percent true you don't just write
something once and then you're done you
write it and it stops then you write it
write it like 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40 45
whatever times and then you're done and
it goes from sock to sort of kind of
suck and then it kind of goes all the
way to awesome and that's the journey it
goes from suck to awesome there are some
other bits but that is more or less it
it's good to say it out loud stay with
me now it feels good
1 2 3 I give myself permission to suck
on a brief administrative note John has
let me know that he's going to give
Henry another week before he makes him
go out and get a job so I will be
filling in for John on Wednesday but
he'll be coming back
after that so one more week I hope you
can I hope you can last that long so
Hank I'll see you on Monday